the netflix series you rachael smith
joined us from madame tussauds new york
in times square rach i'm already scared
already
oh i know right the fear is so real
nichelle but who better to give us
exclusive scoop on season four of you
than mr pen badgely himself
i will find
you one would think that things are
going to pick up in season four oh puppy
ah we what why
but not the case y'all are in london
what gives um look to be real it's
cheaper
i can't imagine having to let go of joe
and then go home to your lovely wife and
kids you know it's like oh let me play
with the toddler now yeah right i don't
i mean yes i have a little bit of fake
blood in my fingernails sorry let me
just i'm like an action star you can
trust me with this secret love
cardi b's really enjoying watching some
joe as well might we see cardi pop up
she did pitch to netflix saying hey i
could be in paris fashion week i mean
you know carter and i still haven't even
met in person we were we were trying to
make something happen ken let e.t
arrange this
for y'all
penn's a busy guy he just finished
shooting episode four of you and he's
co-hosting a podcast podcrushed which
has been reliving the awkward and sweet
moments of middle school the ironic
thing he actually dropped out of school
and traded it for hollywood your first
credit is boy number one on will and
grace in 1999.
i was 12. i know that much insane so you
are living this middle school experience
on television yeah how did that work out
for you i should talk to my therapist
there's something about like bringing
these stories to life how painful that
time is and what are the conditions you
could create that would make that less
painful and more powerful
new episodes drop tuesdays on stitcher
and in each one penn reads an adolescent
story submitted by a listener celeb
guests like drew barrymore amy schumer
and penn's gossip girl co-star lady
meester stopped by too and it was it was
really nice after all this time to just
be
more relaxed and at ease with ourselves
and and reflect on a time when we
weren't
[Music]